We're gonna get this under way and we're gonna have fun with it.
That's, uhhh, that's the rules.
You have to have fun with it, right?
Because when you're in space, you got to have fun or else you just start screaming about the
(Inhale)
(Darkiplier, that you?) Inexhaustible darkness that surrounds you.
(Mark...) The impenetrable crushing weight of nothingness weighing down...
(Mark?!)
...on your soul. The only thing around you is just the
screams that fill up your own head because no one will ever hear you or care (OH DEAR GOD MARK?!)
The universe is just an uncaring endless box of torment built to design to... (MARK COME BACK)
[ glitch sound ]
...hAte itself (MARK PLEASE GOD)
Everyone who ever existed and ever was is only doomed to a destiny to die alone, sad, always (its over hes done it hes lost it)
pondering the endlessness of existence and yet the futility that is life.
There's nothing left for us!
The universe is a big empty tomb! We're all gonna die! A horrible, horrible, death!
... Are you okay?
...Mark?
(◞‸◟；)
and then we're going to play a video game.  (wait what)
So this is space. (What just happened?)
Oh, I know. Oh, it's real pretty.. I-- just you wait. Here we go
[Weird fart noise]
(Ow fuck my eyes) There's the Sun, everyone's blind now. Alright science lesson, number one:
Uhhh..
(Caveman Mark) The big glowing ball of fire that go across sky... Big ball fire?
That Sun! Sun big bright ball fire,
[Unintelligible growl]
Make cavemen inside go: GRR! But not bad.. Good. very good!! (Mark wtf)
big ball fire we call "Sun God".
"Sun God" you pray! You pray to Sun god, it give you food and
Sexy wife!  If you pray hard enough you get good mate, you get good food
And then you get to have good, good time! Make sense?  Aright, everyone pray to Sun god.
Alright, moving on. This is, Kwaererer (what)
Everybody know [*giggles*] Kwayeaear (this caption editing just got 14 times harder thanks mark)
Alright, Kwaiyareiyrar (i give up this is how its spelled now)
You know the darkness you feel inside heart? That Kwaiyareiyrar!
When you pray to sadness inside, you pray to Kwaiyareiyrar! What the fuck is Kwai--? [*chuckles*]
what is...
Kwaiyareiyrar! I don't even know what.. Why is there a little-- wait, what the hell did I just see?? what is this?
What is 2004??
Wha-ha-hat
What are these?! we're so far away!?
Oh my god...
Okay. Well, there's Pluto.
Oh..
Kwaiyareiyrar's out farther than Pluto. Anyway, here's Pluto
Ahh, there it is.
Oh spinning a little fast there, eh Pluto? Okay. So this is Universe Sandbox
so this is a game that allows you to explore all of the uhh
*BIG BREATH*
Elements of the universe and we're gonna start by blowing up the Sun.. (NOOOOO) Kaboom?
OHH too fast! [*laughs*]  (Whoops)
There erebody go! Oh there erybody gone
oh-oh
Jupi..
Oh Jupi I'm sorry [ concerned ]
Alright, okay that was way too -- Chicagoo?!? (what)
The entire solar system blows up and Chicago survives ?? (Chicago survives all)
(Good gawd there be nothing but Chicago)
There it goes !!
Chicag-oh, Chicago, I paused time, Chicago's a-shakin',
Chicago didn't like that too much.
*Giggle Marki*
Why is Chicago alive?
I don't know what happened?
[ chuckling ] how did chicago --
Chicago is strong. Hey y-you're, you're not lying about that shit. Chicago is very strong. You're real jiggly though.
Okay, so wait, where's Kwaiyareiyrar? Kwaiyareiyrar?? NOOO?!
Kopff?
Kopff pleease
oh
Kopff is going. Whoa, Kopff is a fire ball
We're gonna start this over. something went horr- horrifically wrong. All right. So uuuh, I'm gonna go fooooor
Just the - I want the solar system again. Where is just the normal solar system? Solar system, now in real time.
Let's do... not the real time one. cause real time is stupid. Whoa, there's Kwaiyareiyrar
Sedna? Sedna, what are you? Where'd you come from? Look at that. Look how pretty that is... ain't that pretty?
Dats real pretty. Okay. Let's go back to the Sun. Okay. You remember Sun right, you remember Sun? Everybody, Remember Sun?
(Caveman Mark returns) I say big fireball in sky maou-
what da fuuuuck?
Something went flying by, Sirius was that you? W-nO, goodbye. Mercury!
Come back, gonna get you, gonna get you, Mercury!
So. What uh, what I'm - I'm gonna do today is play around
Uhhh... Until I get bored. Let's do a little bit of uh, education
So I've taught you quite a bit about, The Sun!
(mark this is the third time now please your caption editors have families to feed) Big Fire God in sky! Fire God bring rain
if you pray hard enough, along with hot wi- it rain hot wives, AND husbands
[*licks lips for some reason*]
Once you pray hard enough to s-sun god in sky, make sense?
Alright, but now let's, let's carry a few thought experiments
All right?  So the Sun is big right? but it's not that big because I can show you something even *Giggles mid-way* bigger
And it sounds like a euphemism. But hang on. So, UY-Scuti (ooey-scootie) here,
is um, a star,
UY-Scuti is this big.
Compared to our entire solar system, right? Compared to our entire solar system, UY-Scuti is this big.
And if I were to pop it down, it would encompass everything (except your hair)
including
the Sun and
The entire orbit of Jupiter. So let's pop down UY-Scuti there. There's UY-Scuti. What - UY-Scuti? Why are you moving?
Where are you going?
UY-Scuti?!
Where are you going? What? UY?!
Scuti? where is it- wh- where are you going? I didn't put you with any momentum [ chuckles ]
Okay, whatever. Okay, UY-Scuti, I don't know why UY-Sc-let's just get rid of-okay, I gotta restart this
now that's not what I expected to happen
Everybody hold on your heads. Okay. So UY-Scuti's that big, right? so...
Stars, right, stars are just measured,
pretty much by their mass
So this one's one Sun cause it's THE Sun but it's one sun. So one Sun
We can change it up in its size. So let's make this bad boy
Let's make this two suns
it now has the mass of two suns, oH,
Whoa
Okay, so that's weird. I don't know why it says Sun Nova remnant, but it didn't go Nova
So what happened is all of the objects orbiting it
Suddenly fell in a not quite circular orbit
You can even see the little bits of the asteroid belt coming in here. Pretty cool, right? Now. This is just because the Sun
Doubled in size so the gravity well became twice as steep if you know what I mean
So everything spirals off in cool ways like this. Alright, we're going up to three suns
Okay now everything cut in even smaller
Everything's going deeper. That's fine. Let's go up to five suns
There it goes
It's like everything's spinning down the drain see as it gets more massive
It not only gets bigger, but just like everything just spins around it faster because it kind of has to to keep up its orbit
Things how they go faster down there. We're gonna go all the way up to ten Suns
Boom! ooh das a nice spin
So mercury should probably be close enough that it's gonna start bleeding off part of its matter. No, not yet. It's getting hot though
It's real hot. We're gonna go up to 20. This might actually suck in mercury
There we are close up it's fireball, okay Mercury's dunzo Oh Mercury's so dunzo
All right, so Mercury's done (Bye Mercury) for Venus is toasty
Toasty, oh man. I'm surprised none of these have hit each other earth. How's earth doing? I didn't even check in on Earth
How are we doing?
ooh-whoo
Not not good. Not as good as you might think and I don't think very good. Ah
Okay
so, uhh
Chicago's probably doing fine (yeah, probably), but we're not let's go even bigger
let's make this bad boy
A whopping 30 suns and we'll do it, right
there
Gotcha. Let's go back up to like six hours a second
Whoo Venus split up Venus couldn't handle the pressure earth is still going strong though. Venus is dunzo Venus is extremely done though (Bye Venus)
Okay by Veeny Oh, Jupiter coming in to say hello
I didn't even know Jupiter was going over there. I'm surprised Mercury's still there. That should that's not right. Oh
It's slowed down. I don't know. Why are we're going up to 50 this might swallow up everything we know okay 50
It's now so big
Mercury is scraping along its
Atmosphere. I don't even know how Mercury's still even intact. It should not be come though
It is coming so close to the Sun, I don't understand why it's not just absolutely dead (Chicago-level resiliency)
What is iris? iris?
Where did you come from iris?
What the hell where did ir...? Who's iris? how many things are in this solar system? I don't even know uh earth
Oh, no, no earth. No
No, no
Where's Chicago (surviving in the middle of the sun probably) Oh, oh, jeez
Hmm I think that'll buff out. Oh
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that'll buff out
That'll probably buff out. We're going up to a hundo
All right hundo, the Sun is now very big
It's what earth is gone? (Bye Earth)
Well shit
Okay, Mars all on you, baby. Wait. Okay. Well, let's get a close. Look at this one. All right, baby
You got it Marsy baby. All right Mars. How you doing? Oh God where am i going
I Guess we're looking at Juno now. All right Marsy baby. Look you me
Do you have a tail? All right, it's fine you me baby. Here we go we're on Sun approach whoo this is gonna be fun and
[*Laughs*]
Poor Mars, you all right there buddy? You're right. All right, you survived one? I'm sure you'll survive another this is boring
Let's get let's get uh, let's make it 500
There we go. Now we're talking now were
talking oh
Mars hold on. Hold on Mars. You can do it. All right. I don't know what thea is Oh
I meant to give a pep talk to Mars before it made it's pass.
I Guess Mars isn't gonna get that chance. Huh Jupiter is you gonna make it Oh,
Jupiter don't look like it gonna make it but maybe maybe you never know with Jupi. A'ight listen Jupi you got this
I don't know why Thea and Hans are in the middle of you
But Jupe you got this look that sun is a bitch, a pushover
Even you can punch that sun right in the face and you should because you feel good about it, right?
Okay. All right. Listen, Jupi. All right. Listen, here you go, Jew but here's your chance. There's your shot at glory
All right, Jupity-poopity,. All right poopity-scoopity
You're gonna get on you're gonna get out there and you're gonna you're gonna get him
All right, you're already punching him with a uh-oh wait. Okay Jupy poopy. All right. Listen, listen
Listen Jupity, wasn't you got this that sun pushover just to go?
Ohh Ho ho ho
Don't know it cuz you pooped your pants. Oh, oh, oh
You got some acne there, but it's okay. I think oh
that doesn't look good. All right, so Jupy poopy did pretty good
All right. Now, let's stop playing around. Let's make this thing
5,000 it's now five thousand
Times its normal mass. Well, that's boring. Let's make its age like
500 billion. Oh
It's going in. Jupy poopy. Listen. You got this. Jupy poopy. Jupy ooh
Okay. Oh, anomea is palace Aries Vesta. I don't know a and these are I
Let's stop. Let's stop dicking around here. Let's go
(Hello, My Name Is Black Hole) Whoa too big um too big too big. Oops. I am too big
It's not a black hole, what are you talking about? (What, I is black hole) It's fine Pluto
Pluto. Pluto. Listen Pluto. Listen, how you doing Pluto? All right. Listen
All right. You got the eye of the tiger you hear. All right, Pluty. Pluty baby. Pluty baby. Listen that that sun
pushover Pluty. You got this it's your time to shine
Your toy, you know what in fact actually
Mercy kill Pluto before it actually gets to be too far. Listen. This is for your own good Pluto (WOOSH)
Earth goodbye
Goodbye. Oh this way here we go. I missed you by that much. Whoosh. There we go
Where's Pluto
Pluto go. Did you already hit Pluto? What no where'd pluto
What you do with Pluto oh oh (Press F to pay respects for Pluto)
All right, well Pluto is done whoa nice butthole
All right. So that's a weird eye in the middle of os Uranus as a butthole. That's that's oddly fitting
Okay, so you see how that that that this real big you see? Okay. It's got the mass of
500 million suns let's make that five billion just because I want to
Okay, five billion way bigger, right? Okay, everything else has now been swallowed up
It's inside the black hole or whatever if it was a black hole. How do I change my background? Let me change my background
Let's go just stars nad Milky Way dark, and they'll go away bright
brighter nebula green
Wow, that's kinda pretty Skyrim-y nebula purple. There's purple red
Red
cyan
Solid black solid gray solid white that's awful space blue. Oh, that's nice
I like that cuz that gives a little more texture behind everything
space blue green and yellow
space brown perfect poop
space mist
Well, that's kind of what's the difference between that and space blue? Okay, I like space mist
Yeah, that's good stuff, maybe
Yeah, space mist. Okay, good. Wait, what else can I change?
Hang on. I'm busy. All right, that'll be good enough, whatever. It's probably not as good as default, but I don't know
I don't care. I like it. Okay, so you see this thing, right? All right, I'm gonna see what happens when I blow up a
Black hole because I honestly don't know
Some awfully dramatic music for what appears to be nothing happening
Wait, there's suddenly like tons and tons of these Sun nova fragments coming out of nowhere
What did it do anything did it blow up?
Did it blow up oh
(mark how did you even manage this)
ho
(Stunned silence)
I've never seen that before. Well, it most certainly hasn't (wait what)
(Mark how are you even doing this)
Okay, that's weird, okay we
Somehow blew up a black hole (YEAH WE'RE JUST AS CONFUSED AS YOU ARE)
I'm not sure how and I was a little bizarre and I got try that again and its second here. Okay?
All right, black hole pretty big boy. Not as big as our previous big. It's gone. Well, there it is. Oh, no
It's tiny by comparison. It is tiny. Okay. Well, this is a Wimpy baby size black hole
Let make it even bigger even bigger to the 20th huge even okay, this is huge
Real big but there's nothing else to scale to put it by so let's put a galaxy next to it by scale our pinwheel galaxy
right
There Oh big. Okay, so that's the pinwheel galaxy and here's our black hole. So I want to make this
Even bigger. Oh wait nevermind. It's
Way bigger than the Milky Way itself. Where did I put that galaxy? Okay now it's real big
Now it's eve.... That's the maximum in that it could possibly be it is now as big as it could ever
Physically be where did that galaxy go? Did this black hole swallow that galaxy?
Cuz that's an interesting conundrum. Okay, we're gonna blow this thing up again (Not again)
This is now the biggest black hole that you could possibly make in the entire game
Let's see what happens
(A SECOND LIGHT SHOW!!!)
(POOF) And it just
And that's it. Hey, it just go poof. It's just tiny poof and then it go bye-bye. All right. Well, that's
That's anticlimactic
Milky Way right dere
Wait, where'd it go?
Okay, I think I I think I've really royally borked this entire game because it doesn't seem to be working anymore
What is that? Where do we go? Oh
Can I blow you up and blow up a galaxy I blow this up uh oh (goddammit mark)
Shouldn't have done that (nope) Oh
(MARK PLEASE THINK ABOUT THE CHILDREN)
What's going on here
Okay, I don't know what this is definitely not supposed to happen, okay. Oh
All right
Let's just reset this because this is now gotten beyond ridiculous. Good old solar system
okay, so now let's punish earth specifically so earth is
A real good place right real nice. Everybody loves Earth, right?
okay, now imagine and just imagine what if earth was not okay, right, you know like
can you imagine that like if
Kepler...
Kepler, Kepler, Kepler. Oh if Kepler was orbiting. Oh, hi Kepler. Uh-oh, ah!
Shit okay. Well there--there went earth. Okay. Listen about another Kepler Oh
About more? 'Kay, more. there's another one, and another one, and another one, and another one.
(Bass boosted Meme)
How about another one another more more? MORE too many not enough another one or another another
Okay. All right. Here we go. All more keppies Keplors
Okay, cool. All right Keplor Keplor Keplor. Alright, there we go
Okay keep Keplin Keplor Keplor Keplor Keplor
Keplor
Lure
Kepler
Okay, all right
Keplor
Alright, okay wait, where--Twomass. Twomass. Twomass!Two-*chuckles*-mass
Tomb ass
to mass
To mass wools look at 'em spin twoooo mass
Tomb ass oh shit to mass
tomb  ass
TOMB ass to mass
That's its name. It's to mass okay, which one's the main one? Is this a man 1 this is to mass
Or to mask it back beef get your ass back here to mass Oh
To mass kep Kepler her Easter
Kepler did you survive all that? (Chicago tier)
Kepler oh the rampage of to mass never ends Kepler. How did you survive that? I don't even know
I mean, you're not gonna I'm gonna make sure you don't but you know, how
These tiny little baby plants God to a mass tome toe mass. All right to mass listen here
For a second there, I thought the Sephiroth battle music just kicked up
Just like Sephiroth comes in here blows up the Sun he goes shit. I'm sorry. Okay. Let's try this again
Ganymede tiny tiny Ganymede, okay
Listen Ganymede can actually probably orbit in a relatively nice way if it wasn't
Forced into this situation where it's not doing that, you know what I mean our Ganymede
Okay. Now all of you there are struggling to survive, but I'm about to put a kibosh in that idea
Kaboom
Wow, okay way back to the whatever the hell we were doing, okay
So all the Ganymede's you go blow up blow up blow blow blow blow blow blow blow blow blow
I said blow Mars. You're good. You're next. You're next on the chopping block. Okay Mars
everybody knows Mars the shining beacon of
Love in the universe, right? Okay, so imagine if
How about what if we do a
bowling ball
at the speed of light
Okay, there's the bowling ball. What bowling balls gone?
Okay, here's the bowling ball go
Shoom
We're going what's a bowling ball gonna do shot at light speed to Mars?
Dan three two one
Huh do anything they'd do anything it did nothing
There's going sofa I am launching these but it's just going so fast. I can't see it new horizon
No, Tesla Roadster no Great Pyramid
there that had an impact I
Feel like the others would too
Okay, so that worked rival spacecraft. Whoa, that's not where I threw it. But okay, please box
nothing
Nothing Saturn. Why are you flashing over there right there? You see that?
What is it flashing hoots? Good, someone's communicating. Come on Saturn who's there?
Kepler oh you were communicating. Oh well beer. You're welcome. Alright. See ya. Anyway, good. Bye
Bye Saturn Mars. Where's Mars? Have I seen Mars? Why's Mars running? There's Mars. Okay. There we go
So you guys know Mars right? You remember Mars?
I think everybody does so what if instead of that we threw an asteroid at the speed of light. Oh
Okay that
That's that's something okay. That's what they would call a lot of damaged parts of that hurt. What about Pluto at the speed of light?
Curve ball
Well, let's see how fast I can get this bad boy to spin. I keep going. Keep going. Keep going
Let's get some oh, come on there. No, okay. I always got to hit in the direction then it's spinning
There's quite a spin on this bad boy
Was a rotational speed on that one, I have no idea it's broche lobe radius is
1.7 million kilometers and rising what is it? What is that? What's the Roche lobe radius? Hang on. Oh
It's the region around the star in a binary system within the orbiting materials gravitationally bound to that star. So I
Don't know what it means cool to plant it down
I'm gonna do that, but he expect me to do that. I can't do that. It's not within my power
Do you think a comet will do it?
no, that didn't do it a
lot more comets
No, okay oddly enough that didn't seem to do it Eris
No make make no, okay. She seems to be going faster. It's not any cooler. I don't know. Why water
Okay. Alright water. It's now a hundred percent water. Uh
It's not any cooler guys. You might have been wrong about it
It's very uh, not cool. How about if I give it some material?
Water, here we go. I'm gonna shoot some water at it. Ah,
It's like a sprinkler. Here we go. Now we got it. You're gonna cool right down there buddy, boo. Don't worry about it
Let me worry about it. It doesn't seem to be helping much. Oh
It hasn't even reached it yet. Oh
I'm sorry
There goes now. It's reaching it quenching the thirst of it right? Here we go. Oh
Now that's quenched. Oh now that's quench something good. Oh, no, that's real quench
Well, that's quench tastic. Oh, that's so quenched. I might even be quanched
All right. Let's uh some more. Can I get more please? Can we have it faster?
I mean, I can't be waiting around forever for it. Oh, here we go now
Oh, yeah. Now that's a Quanch! Oh, this is real quenchable.
Okay, a nice spiral of Quanch-- Hey! you lazy water bastards!
Does seem to be working? Okay, maybe I need more particles. Alright, let me try this
I'm gonna throw a thousand Jupiter's worth of water at Mars
Here we go. Oh
That's gonna take forever to reach. Ok, whatever. It's gonna hit. This is a thousand Jupiter's of water. Ah, shhhhiiii--*devolves into laughter*
Uh, oops. uh--*Giggles again* Uh, hmmm. Uh, oooh, uh yeeeeh--
What happened to my background, doing? anybody else notice that, my background
thank you
It's still spinning
Okay, Mars not do so good but you know, hey that's alright where's Venus
Venus
Come on over there
How did we get that far out of the system, by the way?
I don't know just me hitting it with so many things I'd eventually just push it so far away you seem to be outlets
Uh, I know there's a way to reset its
Orbits Auto orbit BAM done. Alright rotational period is gonna be one day
Okay, one day one day who?
gonna be
0.5 day. Woohoo. Alright. I know Venus wanted to be just a little more toasty six-hour
rotational period alright, how about it to our
rotational
Okay, we're just gonna Oh
Everybody look away for a second
Just look away. Just look away. Just look like
Venus
Venus I forgot you're going the speed of light. Oh shit. Oh fuck I launched ah shit
Okay
shit
Mercury
buddy
mercury
Listen mercury listen, don't worry about don't worry about what?
the other
Just just don't worry. Okay, you seem worried for some odd reason
Mercury, listen all those other planets were just dumb right? You're not dumb. You're smart
Right? All right mercury if there's one thing I've heard about you, mercury, is that you want some moons
So here's one moon
- here's if I could just.. Now not launch! Okay, not launch
We're gonna orbit the moon is gonna orbit you, okay?
well
There's got to be a tight orbit or you're gonna lose it to the Sun
So you got to really hold on tight to this one. Okay, hold on tight. Okay
And you want one more hold on tight to that. Oh, moon can have a moon
How about a moon for the moon gonna have a nice moon moon? There we go, Moon Moon for the moon
You get a moon - moon
Moon moon moon moon
No, oh. That- that moon can't stay. That's uhh, that's a bad moon. Okay
So mercury has moons which mercury has always wanted moons. I know this I've heard this and
It's gonna be fine
Shit
Shit anyway enough about that that's stupid and dumb. Let's where did everything else in the universe go?
Or the solar system go where Jupiter go why see Jupiter over here Jupiter you trying to run away from me?
Are you going towards? Wait, what's it going towards?
Are you going venus is still going off that way? Where are you going are to mass how are you doing?
How are you doing - mass. All right, listen to mass
I may not have been very nice to you. But I'm gonna give you I'll give you another gas giant here
Two-ton kurrus get. Yep
ton cursed dekap
tun chorus dekap
DD the foie the toast egg door. Yeah. Well, that's dumb. What if I launch him at you?
Is that even hitting you?
Is this even hitting you?
Is this hitting you how do I know that? This is hitting you? Well, it seems to be hitting him. I
Think oh we are cuz we're moving. That's how we got moved out cuz I you hit him Oh cuz I punched him. Oh
That's real
There's real fast and far away, how am I going so fast and let's go faster how fast can we go?
We're going up to a moment of max speed
Whatever the max speed is. I'm hitting it. Oh
Okay, we're now going
Three point three four times 10 to the 14th the speed of light
Huh? I can't even focus on this thing took to mass you. Okay there buddy to mass
2 - Matt OH
-
Boom dome ass
Computers time to scaling seems to be jumping real far too to me
You you're breaking all senses of logic a rotational period let's make it point
oooo 1 so now it's spinning super fast -
Can I zoom in on oh shit Oh
Where's to mass? Ok, err its to miss ok to mass trying to land on to mass
- shit. Oh god. Oh god. Oh
I apparently I've landed on to mess but it's so broken the laws of physics at this point that I don't think there's any way
that it could possibly
Actually not just be awful. Ok, zooming out again woof. All right, you know what? I'm just gonna let that go Oh, oh
My god, I'm zooming in there. We are
That's how far away we were where's to mass to mass? There's do a mass
Oh
God, oh god, look at everything else. It's struggling just to calculate the speed of to mass. Oh god
Oh god, all positional accuracy has gone out the window!
It is just too fast!
Alright, hang on, I think we broke it okay we figured out what broke it
So let's go out of here all plants all moons. Saturn is just. Oh, my god Saturn is dripping with moons
Good god Satur- Woahhh...
Ya greedy bitch. Look at you. Where's, I know Jupiter? Oh my god. Look, I know Jupiter has tons of oh my god
Okay, Jupiter you big fucking show-off Oh
Mark impersonating Jupiter: "I'm Jupie. Oh, I'm jupetitetoopeter! Oh, I'm jupitupiter!
Oh look at me. Mr. Big shot with all my moons!" Even Earth has more than one moon
technically if you're gonna buy that
Doesn't done earth have more than one moon?
Okay, nevermind I'm just a fucking idiot I do.. I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about only one moon here. Okay
Nevermind.. Mars you and your two moons two piece-of-shit Dinko moons
Stupid idiot. Venus you got any moons?. No moons?!
No moons?
No moons! Really? That's stupid
Mercury no moons? Ahh that's dumb. Pluto. I bet Pluto's got new-- moo- moons.. Pluto's not even here
What kind of solar system is this?
Okay. What am I doing here? What was I supposed to be doing?
I had a reason for pulling this up with the moons, but I can't remember what it is
Force?
Force equivalent to fourteen point six three. Well, that's boring the force equivalent to a galaxy
What would that do? What the fuck?
Jup-- ittery?!
Jupiterie?!
What's Jupiterie?!
Wha-.. Wha- WHAT?!
The ffffffuck! We just...
Wait, no..! We were just zoomed into.. Whhhh?!
Wait...
Wait, no...
Oh
Ohhhh! Wh- Wh.. Ohhh!!
We pushed the m- the sun. Oh..
Why is it Jupiterie?
Jettison, I guess that's what force would do, huh? Okay, let's push it back
We gotta push it back guys. Come on go back home
Are you going you going home?
How are you going home? I don't know are you I
Don't know what this
What the fuck is this rave show doing
Today, what is it doing? Is it?
doing um
Okay
Let's just just blow this up for now
Okay, and it's gone, I guess that's all there is to that. Alright, see ya. Let's go back to Jupiter II
I want to see what this does. Okay, we're gonna go super slow cuz I don't know what this is doing this force thing
So we're just gonna go here. We're gonna force this and go (great sound effect) boink
*processing*
Did that do
Anything it's not doing
Nothing, it's doing nothing. It's doing a whole lot of nothing. What's it doing?
What's it doing wait a shot met is straight wait, oh it is doing something wait
Wait, no, it's wait. How when did we do something?
Well, you thought I well I thought I would have seen that and why is it was it weird, huh?
What does it do it? What? Okay, let's go up to a whopping 10 milliseconds a second. Okay?
Alright bye they're all going
Love Jupiter <3
Blob Jupiter, you know actually pulled up put a black hole at all this just kibosh. This is it. Goodbye Right. See ya
You're all going in and then I'm gonna blow up the black hole. No. Thank you
kaboom
Alright, so that's done
What about Uranus? What about Uranus?
Ok, Uranus, I'm gonna launch some stuff into this butthole here. - Gonna launch a bunch of moons in here
(everything is a euphamism)
Gypped duped duped is coming for that moon, baby
Duped is coming coming straight for that butthole Oh what?
Don't be shy what what the hell's happening (come on)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
But the butthole moved
Can you imagine if you're looking up in the sky and then you're and it's just like blinks and then moved away
It blow it up
Alright enough of that. Let's get back to the normal solar system planet 9 in our solar system. What does that mean Pluto?
Alright, so I'm gonna do
Something I'm gonna launch a black hole at the solar system here there right there Darris you go
Nevermind. Oh shit. Oh
Okay, well that
that went that one different than I thought it would we're gonna we're gonna get off the uh,
We're gonna get off the human scale. What the fuck dice
Dice these are some really flat. These aren't dice. Oh
They are they're just Oh
are the oh
Oh, I see
Oh, let's blow it up
Kaboom kaboom
boom, boom bam boo boom boom clap boop boop
Boo boo P and Boop. Oh, that's cool. I didn't even think about that
Orbiting a bowling ball
Whoa
That's so cool, that's cool
We do something else I wanted to do let me I want to see something about a son
You know, I want to see what happens if our son
Because they said that you could age it. So let's let's age this thing
Immensely, let's go
Let's go like fifty thousand years a second. Well, maybe this isn't even nearly enough. Yeah, we need to go way faster
Let's go five hundred thousand years a second. It's still too slow. Let's go fifty million not still too slow
Billy in a second
There it goes look that bad boys getting big
All getting big and beefy. Whoo. Oh
That was it. That was it
That was it. That was it. That was it. That's all you're gonna do
Uh-uh, okay. Hang on. Wait, hang on wait. Yeah. No, I don't want to edit it
No, I don't want to edit it. Delete it. Okay. Hey, hang on. Hang on. I'm gonna add
This big boy who is scooty, we're gonna age it you're gonna get all old and wrinkly now eventually
I think you're gonna go kaboom ain't ya maybe?
No
Denebola
Wait, it did go Nova
Mar thiis why are these just
What's happening
What the heck? What what? What did
Serious B what the Frick Canis Majoris?
What is happening?
Why Oh
God Oh No Oh
I think we're starting to disappear into the horizon of forever
Yep. Okay, we've frozen the whole game is crashed. Oh
I don't know what we were doing
But we did
something
Okay
I'm gonna go out of this and we're going to go into the Galactic scale not
Necessarily the normal scale we're gonna go into the galactic scale
And wait many stars. Whoo
Oh, that's cool. Oh, that's cool. Oh
Look at that go Oh bye wolf where you go wolfy wolfy. Oh
Whoa rave show aside. We're gonna go on to
Stress test. Oh hell yeah. Oh oh, oh
Okay, let's do the thousand plans first. Let's go that one. We're a stress test this bad boy. Oh
To stress my computer can't handle two struts - stress - stress
Okay, uh hmm Oh to stress. Okay to stress - OH to stress. Okay. Let's just try
Let's try five thousand moons. That's probably less stress
I don't know why it's not going there. I think I might have to force quit out of this because I think it's just broken
Yeah, probably I'm gonna force quit out of this
Goodbye
(Well guys..)
(Fun having ya :) )
(Subscribe to PewDiePie)
(BUHBAI!)